bienvenue mon grand bain j'espère que tu
n'as pas trop perdu de se réclamer un
client premier trimestre alors nous a
offert exercice 4 avec les doubles
croches
aujourd'hui éric à son professeur pour
lui tout seul après 12 semaines
d'interruption des cours la reprise est
timide
même s'il est équipé chez lui et qu'il a
pu s'entraîner le retour en cours et
pour ce musicien un bol d'air frais ben
enfin vous de soulagement ce bon ça
c'est long quand même trois mois donc
sans batterie enfin moi je m'ennuyais
d'art car la musique doit raisonner
pas facile dans un quartier ou un
appartement de s'exprimer sont retenus
surtout lorsque l'on apprend
la batterie son instrument une
particularité c'est qu'on ne peut pas en
disposer chez soi comme on veut et en
pratique et comme on veut ici c'est un
espace qui est dédié à la pratique
instrumentale et qui est bénéfique pour
tout le monde
ça fait quoi de retrouver cet échange
justement c'est déjà un lien social
c'est déjà aussi une manière de
pratiquer de manière collective alors en
temps normal jacky alpha à 12 sessions
99 par semaine pour cette reprise en fin
d'année le sermac a fait un petit
sondage un tiers seulement des 3000
élèves sont prêts à revenir
pourtant la saison des ateliers est
prolongé jusqu'à la fin du mois de
juillet fait de voir que les athéniens
ont repris ce matin dans de bonnes
conditions peut-être que ça va les
motiver
en tout cas nous nous sommes là pour ces
stagiaires de retour
le confinement a été studieux et
l'animatrice présente grâce aux échanges
de photos sur internet on a continué
comme ça en accompagnement soit d'un
tableau déjà commencé soit d'un nouveau
tableau
il ya un moment donné ou par contre
l'accompagnement a ses limites et
certains gestes ne peut pas être montrée
par mail donc là on était content de
pouvoir montrer le geste pour les
cheveux notamment et oh là là je vous
assure c'est du pur bonheur
je pense que ça me manquait d'ailleurs
chaque lundi je faisais je descendais
refaire deux fois ci revenait toujours
faire un petit tour par ici dans
l'espoir de rencontrer les amis des
plans de diesbach un bonheur enfin
partager car l'art tous les arts ont
vocation à être partagée